hello grammarians today paige and i are
going to teach you all about your new
best friend the comma
it is a piece of punctuation that has
many many many functions um and we're
just going to broadly overview them
today the comma is an extremely
powerful piece of punctuation it can do
a whole bunch of stuff so paige what is
like the most
pertinent or important thing that the
comma does i would probably say
that it is separating sentence elements
okay
so that's like it's
broad super power
exactly but it can also but lots of
stuff falls under that
okay
so it's like it has
laser vision but it can not only use
that laser vision to like boil water but
it can also
cut through
steel exactly so this is like a super
superhero punctuation mark
i'll make that into a c for comma
so okay so how is the comma going to
save the day today how's it going to
make our sentences make sense what are
some of the things that it separates
uh so it can separate
elements of lists
um what's so like
for lunch i had
tofu
comma
spam
comma
and seaweed
sorry hawaiian lunch
delicious um so that's that's some
that's a way in which we can so it's
separating these elements of this list
um
i guess commas can also separate
dates
that's right dates and times so for
example here in the united states
national blueberry muffin day is july
11th
and if we wanted to refer to a
historical blueberry muffin day let's
say july 11th
comma
1981
wow it was the best muffin day ever that
i wish i could have been around yeah
okay so so a comma can separate
lists and it can be used for dates and
we can also like set off things at the
beginning of sentences like basically
everything is great right
so the comma has like a bunch of
different functions it's like this super
useful multi-tool it's the superhero of
a piece of punctuation so we're not
going to cover all of that in this video
the most important thing to remember
about the comma is what it does is
separate sentence elements it can it can
separate clauses it can separate items
in a list it can separate dates um
usually when you're trying to
make a separation within a sentence
you use a comma
so paige what are some things that
commas can't do
that's a great question so
commas can't go at the end of a sentence
okay so i couldn't be like
i want
to go swimming
comma and that would that couldn't like
i couldn't end a sentence that way you
need to say something after the class so
this is this is no good yeah or or you
have to keep going like i want to go
swimming
and then
sailing
and end it with a period like that yes
okay so that
would be fun that's totally fine usage
for a comma if it's in the middle of a
sentence but not at the end of a
sentence right okay so commas only go in
the middle
yeah so comma separates stuff which
therefore means it has to be on it has
to be in between something right there
has to be something to the left and
something to the right cool
all right
that's that's a comma yeah would you say
i think we have successfully met the
comma cool you can learn anything david
out page out